والله يا
جماعه نفسنا احنا ما نوريكم ايش بصير بس
مجبرين الجريمه هان كبيره الجريمه كبيره
كبيره جدا داخل مستشفى كمال عدوان انسحبت
وتراجعت قوات الاحتلال من داخل هذه
المستشفى لكن اتينا الى
المكان لكن تفاجانا مما
حدث
جماعه هذه الجريمه الذي ارتكبها
الاحتلال بحق مستشفى كمال عدوان
لكن شاهد هان حجم
الاجرام بحق المصابين هذا جثمان احد
المصابين الذين كانوا داخل المستشفى
الجرافه خبطت عليه
ومشت الجرافه خبطت عليه ومشت مش قادرين
نوصف
المشهد جثامين بالعشرات الجرافات خبطت
عليهم مشت كله جثامين
جثامين لا نستطيع تحمل الرائحه هنا في
المكان المش هد صعب جمين في كل مكان كما
نشاهد هنا تحت التراب حسب شهود عيان عشرات
النازحين والمرضى
والجرحى تحت هذا
التراب هذا جزء مما نستطيع توثيقه الان
لكن الجريمه كبيره
جدا يا
الله حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل وستبقى
التغطيه مستمره ان شاء الله
ا